good morning john i did a search on
twitter yesterday just four words hank
john green and sane and i kind of have a
lot to say about the fact that a lot of
people
think that we are the same person i want
to argue that number one
this isn't all bad and two it might it
might be that we are actually a little
bit the same person and that's why
people are confused
we'll get there first as to why it might
be a little bit of a good thing here
ciara says it well i was like wow so
versatile
which is something that i would both
love to be and also
like people to think about me so hey one
thing i noticed when i was going through
the
amazing analytics that alexander daly
put together for the vlog with this
channel was that like you and i
are good at different things the videos
with the most views
are more likely to be mine while the
videos would the best like to dislike
ratio are almost
always yours that's reflective of a
reality both that like you and i have
different skills but also that we're
we're energized by different things i
think it's safe to say that you're often
kind of reigning me in while i'm often
kind of drawing you out so it's nice to
not just like have double the amount of
time
in having this partnership but also
different
interests and skills this is why people
work together and in order to work
together to some extent
it's very helpful to have a shared
identity and that's the other thing here
because we've been doing this together
for so long
and because our careers are tied
together
and our our community is tied together
our content is tied together we are
tied together in a way that is i think
really healthy this kind of shared
identity where like the success of one
person
is the same as the success of the other
i think some people might find it weird
but i
i bet you that it is actually
historically
the opposite thing is weird where we
only consider our own success as our
success but i'll tell you it's
definitely nice because when you succeed
i don't feel any competition toward that
because i feel like it is my success
in fact it's kind of better than my
success john i just got your book in the
mail
and i sort of started leafing through it
to like look for some of the easter eggs
which
have been fun to find but then i've
started reading it
and then i an hour went by and i had
read up quite a lot of it i was
surprised by how easy it was to get
sucked in i think a big part of that is
that
i imagine us as as having a lot of
joined identity
and yet there's a lot about you i don't
know and having gone through a bit of it
what it feels like to me right now
like the biggest sensation i have is
that it feels like a success and
obviously that is not my success and yet
i still feel really good about it this
is something that is very
good when you are connected enough to a
person that their success
which they are experiencing in really
complicated ways where they're
gauging whether it's enough success or
not or whether it's legitimate success
or whatever
we do to try and diminish our own
accomplishments
you experience in a very simple way look
at this amazing thing
that this person made i don't have to
think about all the work that went into
it about whether it was worth that word
all i have to think is
wow this is a book that isn't like any
other book ever
ever ever and yet it does a thing that
is so extremely
hard to do it's almost like
you're really good at this and if
someday people think i
wrote it or they think that you make
science videos
awesome being an individual is really
hard and i have to do it almost all the
time and so to know that there are
people's heads in which i'm not doing it
it's a little bit of a release and to
know that in reality there are ways that
i
share my identity with you and my
parents and my wife and my son and i get
to share not just
the time that i have as an individual
but my very imagining
of my identity my imagining of my
individuality
that it includes those people to realize
that i am often imagining myself
as more than just one person which i
think is actually pretty reflective of
the reality of what
humans are john i'll see you on tuesday